[Music]
yeah
you know what's Friday night feeling
right here you're going out with your
friends catching it on snapchat and I'm
only 17
ladies holler kiss on the homecoming
king when I step up in the spot I'll be
taking the shots with the girls that are
hot with the bucket that I bought I know
you keep it now we just hear and we
chilling out
[Music]
Dilli took a picture online
Shelly what are you doing I'm drunk
Dylan you can't post those things when
I'm drunk
my dad's gonna see me and kick me out of
the scouts don't tag
don't take don't take don't tear it
don't take don't take it
don't don't oMG finally the weekend
leaving the office illa man sees a party
till 6:00 a friend nine to six chillin
with my clique and random energy turns
up like Leo in the world the walls
that's right even though I'm barely
making it [ __ ] bottles x- bulletin
page it's on the tip what the heck whoa
unless you tag me Shane we're supposed
to be at the quarterly office retreat uh
I think it's already in the cloud I'm
sorry
[Music]
don't tear it
don't take don't take it
[Music]
then I'm outsmarted snow on the floor
somebody making another super
independent price I'm trying to be in
stable independent and war but tonight
when I go up on the button on the floor
in case I meet a guy who's had me and I
kick where I make more money than him
right now guys we're having fun here and
everything but I don't want a picture
online where I'm making more money then
adieu it's gonna turn guys off it's like
a whole woman's right thing in America
right now
[Music]
don't take don't take don't don't
[Music]